what do you think you see something
today we identified containers that were
coming from the Dominican Republic these
were manifested as avocados all right
and so then you picked it up from what
you are
when we brought them through the X-ray
we were able to identify that they
weren't full
containers we identified an area that
looked like it was freshly
pop there
yeah we got to drill those ones I think
still all right let's do
it let me let me hit it be
[Applause]
careful nice that should be good there
you go to hit it with the crar right
there we go there we
[Music]
go I see I see Brick you see it you see
it it's loaded dude load
it
yeah look at it all bro look at it all
make sure you have gloves on make sure
you have masks
on
done eight n these Commodities we don't
know what they are and they can be
deadly it could be fentanyl a small gram
of fentanyl could kill you so that's why
we use safety precautions masks and
gloves to protect our
guys the job gets tedious sometimes you
know know you get down you get dirty you
crawl through ships and you keep looking
and looking and you know after a while
it starts to think why am I doing this
there's
more and then when you finally hit it
you get the load it's like it's all
worth it now you
know
what we do now is we put it into one of
our test kits to verify what kind of
substance it is whether it's an illegal
substance Like Cocaine
bentin positive for
cocaine 140 so faru we got another
container we just pulled in another
container that might be loaded as well
cuz they're linked together the search
never stops and neither do the
traffickers
go you want to open your trunk for me
and turn your vehicle off as you can see
we have various types of vehicles
various types of Travelers everybody's
trying to get to the United States I get
the by my experience under the eight
years working here with uh with CVP we
see a lot of alien smogling
boy
[Music]
some of these undocumented for Nationals
start looking to better their lives we
totally understand that the problem is
these human smuggling organizations are
transnational criminal organizations
that are exploiting these individuals
it's a money-making machine for them
they're putting lives at Jeopardy
anybody need water the criminal
realizations have no care for human life
human and safety can you stand up come
on you're okay
snn it is important for us to stop this
because we're going to continue to see
lives
lost we're literally right on the
Mexican border the ability for these
undocumented foreign Nationals to
circumvent the fence line and get across
and then get into the community is
really
quick there's St houses here where
they're holding big groups and then they
start moving toan to Albuquerque if they
going all the way to the North like New
York Detroit they may pay
$15,000 for one
person he
five
semi we have a semi Tru that's coming
down the wrong way down the bridge and
we have to have K9 go sweep it in order
for it to make entry from the United
States we just have to do a secondary
inspection on it there could be anything
from Contraband narcotics to people
human trafficking they opened up a truck
just like that not too long ago and
that's where all those dead bodies
were can we open the
doors
there's a lot of space in there to hide
a lot of things and could be false sides
they could have loaded up the
baseboard there's many places to hide
stuff
there initial Hands-On inspection
nothing really pokes out at us at the
moment but we always run K9 on it just
in
case negative inspection
this truck here more than likely is um
legitimate travel but unfortunately
people have suffocated in the back of
trucks like that so it's very very
important that we check those trucks
thoroughly for Contraband and for safety
of
[Music]
people
hello guys where are you guys coming
from today from Columbia where were you
today did you do a little shopping out
there just come with me real
quick there's no quick reference guide
to the way people conceal
items I look for passenger Behavior dur
interactions with other passengers are
they on the phone a lot are they texting
all of those things that passengers do
most of them have a meaning after you do
this enough you can actually
tell where's your passport
sir how are you today fine where you
coming from G just come with
me the reason I stopped him is because
when he opened his passport he had $100
bills just falling
out what's your reason for travel today
sir I'm going for a qura program okay
where is the uh the money that was in
your passport the money show it to
me why would you keep money in your
passport take it
[Music]
out all right make sure you have all
your money all right put your money
away put your bag up
here how long is your program for sir
June to September
and it's called green heart exchange
green heart exchange what what kind of
work housekeeper where do you know where
you're going at Tennessee you're going
to Tennessee yes how are you getting
there from here I'll book the flight
show me let me
see who is the person that just
snapchated
you my cousin is that person here yes
where don't answer that who is that
anyway same person don't no answer is he
meeting you here he's taking me to the
Delta of his so I can travel to Tennesse
I don't understand that Delta Airlines
is in this terminal
why so he's going to show him
his his his he for
me before I open this bag I want to ask
you another question are you bringing
anything into the United States with you
for anyone else no please you didn't
bring anything for him look everything
is
mine This Guy's in an awful rush to talk
to
you the way I think is hey I'll buy you
the ticket bring this into the United
States for me or or do this for me I
don't know but that's just the way I
look at
things yo flight is in 40 minutes and
yet you're going to have time to go see
this person no he's he's he's taking me
there but you're
here that doesn't make any
sense and this guy doesn't
stop got the knife
it
the we were looking at different
containers coming from incoming
countries that were of high
risk get the other pin we got to get the
other
pin the people that smuggle the drugs
they put so much effort into concealing
it they welded and riveted a new piece
of metal in front it looked all
normal back in the day they used to just
put pallets of it on there but not no
more man this really concealed deep
now
101 two
three up
top got
[Music]
the there's
more
140 and the other container
127 it's been several years since we
found a load this large in one
day this is a cold hit we never know
what shipment we're getting guys work
really hard day in and day out this a
big payoff for us we're very
excited another 45
pieces and then we just got to wait each
[Music]
we're contacting HSI they're going to
take the investigation further and
search for where these drugs were
intending to go to in the first place so
we got about 142 keys total about 73 72
between each they're getting it all set
up and loaded once we sign it off to you
guys so on you whatever you guys need us
to do from there on okay that's good
brother
as I was expecting him his phone started
to ring off the hook it must have rang
six times and the fact that it just kept
ringing off the hook didn't make any
sense to
me why they so much that's the thing
though I don't get it I don't get it
either who's calling who's that who is
that c cousin
he would you for me and he didn't ask
you to bring anything into the United
States for him at all are you carrying
anything on your body for anyone
else this this bothers me because how do
we know that they didn't force this guy
into come in here and he might not be
going anywhere
right
he looks I don't want to use the word
vulnerable but it you know looks like he
doesn't know any
better nothing
nothing who's
that this my M okay
so I think he he called it and then he's
telling her that I'm not picking his C
so call me in okay after a little while
the caller that appeared on the phone
was his mom so that brought things a
little more clarity maybe because he
wasn't picking up that guy's calls the
guy might have worried and called his
mom and said look your son's not
answering the phone why don't you try
and that sort of brought the inspection
down all right
here you're all set once I was satisfied
that there was nothing wrong there I
just handed him back his passport and I
let him go be careful out there all
right all right I don't know this what
it is yeah do what you got to
do
yeah
so the primary focus with CDP officer is
the here at the Port
Adventure but however we do have
Travelers that try to come in where it's
not the aort of
Entry where we as CDP officers cannot be
our job here is limited but along the
border you have water Patrol that is
protecting the Border
itself border patrol our counterparts
will actually monitor the land in
between a Port of Entry that land in
between a Port of Entry is usually used
to circumvent entering the country
legally and Amo also assists by
monitoring via helicopter or any other
method that they're able to
use go ahead start securing doors come
off coms the passware branch covers a
approximately 823 Mi of linear
border CG FL F somewh good slide left it
looks clear on the
ground on a day-to-day basic operation
for us we will go out we'll support Port
Patrol from the air the pilot and the
enforcement agent that's sitting in the
opposite seat from him if they come
across the group of migrants they have
the capability of reaching out via radio
to the ground components of border
patrol and help them make whatever
arrests need to be made in those
situations that'ss good make your box
out by 68 good start on the
inside unfortunately these migrants uh
they come with a big dream they're not
told or they are misled as to the
dangers they're going to be facing and a
lot of these cartels are a lot of these
human trafficking organizations don't
really care about the people that
they're pushing across the
border it's a business and they're only
getting better and better at the
business so they're finding new ways to
always throw us for a loop or throw
someone else for a loop
[Applause]
there's some uh people right here prob
waiting there's like at Le three or
four there's another two on our left
hand side a little further down they
already are in the United States they're
already
in coms with the ground yeah this sounds
like a job for horse
control the bush at the one in the great
Shir is walking towards there's another
five and
there 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and then the other Bush to the right
there's about four in
there Patrol coming
in he's running from the
agent he just caugh that uh
signle organizations well sometimes
they'll send five or six groups and
other times it'll be maybe just one or
two at a time and space it out so
they're they're pretty good about not
being consistent just when you think you
have like it figured out they'll throw a
curveball right now they'll all be
searched and then they'll be put into
that transport van they'll be taken to
the station uh once everything the
situation becomes calm uh just making
sure everybody's good they're in good
health they'll do a interview and get
into the direction that they can
traveling and uh on the smuggling
organization as
[Music]
well
HSI comes in and what they usually do
with us is that we trade off some of the
cocaine so that they can try to track it
to the original source of where it was
intending to go all right guys thanks
for coming out today our CBP Partners
got approximately 150 kilos this is is
associated to a large scale drug
trafficking organization so we're going
to attempt to control delivery down in
the Miami area these guys could be armed
so once we make entry into the location
get everybody safe and secured on the
ground do your searches hopefully we can
get some arrest today let's go do this
this operation it could take anywhere
between 2 hours it could take 2 or 3
days we're not on our schedule we're on
the B guy
schedule we have uh multiple units on
the ground and we're going to deliver
the
container heading westbound should be
jumping on
595 the location of where we drop off
the container individuals that are there
will maybe try to attempt to extract the
uh
narcotics we also have to focus on who
we're dealing with violent drug
trafficking organizations so yeah for
sure we always have to be on high alert
and just move forward and you know try
to
Cy did make the left hand
turn yeah I'm going to go ahead and set
up down the
street at our
location all the way to the
fling we we arrived at the Final
Destination we are currently awaiting
any activity as far as if somebody comes
and accepts the container from the
person delivering it so uh we're in a
waiting game we got a long night ahead
of
us it's not uncommon for the individuals
to wait when there's nobody around
anymore all the businesses have closed
and they wait for you know Darkness to
fall so they can start you know taking
stuff out when nobody's really
around rockes there we
go don't get close to them they're going
to be looking for I'm here but I'm like
two blocks away
one walk with the DU B to the
front right there definitely if you got
a Target Crouch down as hands and
knees bleach
here somebody
outside you're walking towards that
vehicle all right look like they're
leaving for Let It
Go the doors were closed I'm thinking
that they were kind of just like sizing
it up and see if anybody showed up but
they definitely didn't even attempt to
open that yeah all right there you guys
P out okay
[Music]
brother so the two Targets that were at
the location um departed um in a in a
vehicle that came to pick him up uh some
units followed him right
the uh Target container still at the
location and we would maintain eyes on
the container um all through the night
into the
morning passport
flee how long we outside the United
States 7even days what was your reason
for travel
birthday you have a nice day all right
thank
you how you doing sir can I see a
passport please where you coming from
today ready all just come real quick I'm
just going to take a quick look in your
bags just place your bags up here for me
what was the purpose of your trip to my
how long were you there like month a
month are these gifts this the gift for
[Music]
okay definitely feels like Christmas
morning when you got to unwrap
everything but I don't see my name on
any of these gifts so I guess it must
have been a bad boy this
year
Ginger oh
Ginger if it's not dried then it might
not be
allowed thank
you the ginger is usually okay but he's
got to be clean something like this you
know it's contaminated the store
with those these are okay these are
okay
[Music]
this it's a portrait of the passenger I
was inspecting it just really heavy give
me one second right taking a look at the
picture just based on recent Trends
folks have been using picture frames as
a concealment method and so when I saw
it and I felt the weight my suspicion
level went from here to there and I had
to take a closer look to see
what check the
line and I try to be delicate while
still you know being able to do my job
and inspect the portrait to see what's
inside of
there
this is dry
P satisfied with
that the material used to create the
portrait was what caused it to be so
heavy have a good day thank
you
water Pion received information on un
possible human smuggling Stash House we
regularly get about two to three leads
the week we're about to go see if this
information we got is any
good so a lot of our our traffic will
initiate in Al Paso and uh they're
success
with their smuggled attemp a pickup
driver will usually pick them up here
and take them to a stash house sometimes
people will run into a stash house and
find four smuggled humans sometimes you
find 20 sometimes you find
60 we'll find Firearms we'll find
narcotics times they're Gang Related
that's where some of the violence can
come in they could have uh weapons
holding them against their will asking
for higher smuggling fees from the
family and just holding them there
sometimes the caretakers can go even
further and sexually assault them
physically assault them so it's
important to uh go to all these houses
not just because there's a crime being
committed but also because there's
possibly crimes being committed against
the smuggled
[Music]
humans one thing I don't like about
about doing knocking talks sometimes you
go knock and you hear people moving
around the house hopefully they're just
trying to hide and avoid you but they
could be setting you up for an ambush
ready to retaliate against
you the more time they go without
answering the more nerve-wrecking it
gets police
[Music]
Polie
can you step out for
us here bro you have any weapons on you
n there anyone else in here report that
there's
like he let us
in
yeah the dude's high as since we're
suspecting he's under the influence of
some kind of narcotic we decided to
search the the house for any Contraband
Firearms trucks anything indicative of
human smuggling ledgers money type of
food that they feed
them
anything we didn't find any smuggled
humans in the house but from what we
know in the investigation and what what
we see in there is he allegedly smuggled
humans in the past he has self admitted
to being gang affiliated and they
running some checks doing a little more
investigating see what's going to happen
with
him while we were here we received
information on another possible human
smuggling Stash House so we're going to
head on from here to there and see if we
find anything
there
[Applause]
every officer's assigned a personal
radiation device this will let us know
if anything within our vicinity has
radiation so as I was making my rounds
with the device where the signal was
stronger as I got to the
passenger
gr hello
ma'
[Music]
you know radiation it could be dangerous
it could be used as
weapons so we have to make sure that
it's it's not a an instrument of Terror
that somebody's trying to bring in to do
harm into this
country how long were you in the
Dominican
Republic
okay
nothing yes she had thyroid um she had
thyroid
surgery what I've encountered at the
airport when a passenger is being
treated with radiation is sometimes they
they put this D in the person so they
when they do a CT scan the image can
read a little better so if the person
has has ingested that die it'll it'll
trigger
this and she supplied the proper medical
paperwork and it shows the actual
chemical she was treated with oh I
131 okay I 131 okay
yeah okay so she's free to
go got
[Music]
you
B you got a pretty good eye of there
right I got we're back again for day two
the overnight surveillance teams we're
still sitting on the
container multiple people have come and
gone every once in a while they'll enter
the container go to where the narcotics
are concealed and look around come back
out walk
around once they make end entry or
access the compartment where the
narcotics are we will make entry but as
of right now we're just uh in a holding
[Music]
pattern Su pulling in now headed
southbound through the lot on the north
entrance one of the targets uh came back
and has been inspecting the interior of
the container
one of the ground units saw him with a
drill so there's a chance that um now
that it's daylight they could be taking
the opportunity to access the container
um hidden
compartment just
away
color looks like they ACC just the TR
hold one or two breaks out get their
hand in there
okay all right guys heads up heads up
bleach haired guy is standing on the
sidewalk looking at the B
[Music]
now all units move in grab that
[Applause]
[Music]
guy where's the location
which is the
location hey cover let's
go everything's closed up there's nobody
in
there once we apprehended the subject we
cleared the area to make sure U there
wasn't any threats for law enforcement
so we uh cleared the container of course
uh we also cleared the building that the
individual was so make sure there wasn't
any suspects in there and of course the
surrounding parking
lot we got him in custody he's uh
probably on the lower end tier of uh the
drug trafficking organization so we try
to work our way up to the next
individuals that are here in South
Florida and then from that point then we
work our way to uh Caribbean or South
Central
America clear
[Music]
out
we're going to a house in s Park New
Mexico we're going to be looking for
smuggled humans inside this house house
and uh if we do find them we're going to
look to question probably somebody who
lives there and see if they're the
caretaker or involved in any way and uh
try to get as much information from the
investigation to hopefully do an arrest
based on probable
cause
[Music]
you got
one all right we're on our way over
there
someone popped their head out of the
trailer this one or the silver one I
think it's the silver one out there yeah
they said that they saw one run in as
soon as they saw
[Music]
us
let's go let's go good boy so right now
those bags over here are from the
Dominican Republic and uh we're just
waiting for the passengers to come and
claim them because in the last couple of
months it's been a very successful
flight to search
ke Mexico okay thank
[Music]
you me see your
passport just follow
[Music]
them
okay and unama okay the GU is coming
from the Dominican Republic which was a
flight that we were targeting for
narcotic smuggling and when I went
through his luggage I found pills that
were removed from their packaging and
placed into some other kind of wrapping
stuck in
sneakers uh which made it appear like he
was trying to be deceptive and having
them hidden from
us he says there're
1500 viagra
pills the guy has enough of them he gets
arrested okay bang it's the generic
brand of Viagra which is very expensive
in this country and where he's coming
from it's not that expensive here you
need a prescription over there you don't
don't I guess we're going to go to the
pat down room make sure he's not hiding
anything and wait for
[Music]
instructions who's a pill
store
[Music]
and he's supposed to sell them to
who
for how
much how much did he buy them
for he says they're
yeah most likely they're going to get
seized
okay here's
300 it's the generic brand of
Viagra and we counted 2019 pills and
they're sold on the street for10 to $20
a
pill
this product was made in another country
and we don't know what kind of quality
control they have can potentially be
harmful these are
prohibited
thank prosecution was declined and he's
going to be sent back to the immigration
side because he's a tourist he's going
to be sent back to his country and his
Visa is going to be cancelled because he
said that he's going to sell them for
$1,000 which is a violation on the terms
of his Visa unauthorized employment and
he's going to be put on a plane
eventually after they take a statement
and do an expedited
[Music]
removal
what happened so there's a group in
there he said the driver that dropped
her off 10 days ago in there okay I
don't know if there's anybody else
[Music]
there
we need to get
in they've talked to two smuggled humans
already and they said there's probably
more inside the driver that dropped off
the female that was out here earlier is
is still
here so now they'll knock and hopefully
get
consent
gun where are the other
people inside this house and need can
call them out stay there yell at him
get
them we continued the investigation got
consent to go in and we found a total of
16 smuggled humans
inside of those 16 I believe eight were
from Mexico and it were from
Guatemala we found almost we found like
half the
group inside the the main Walling right
here and they were just scattered
throughout in different rooms hidden
behind televisions hid in closets and
then the other ones were inside this
aluminum trailer right
here the conditions as you can see are
not anything that most of us are used to
living in that Trader doesn't have any
air conditioning that's where they're
staying considering the temperatures how
hot it's been getting these past couple
weeks I think today we're reaching
temperatures above 100 one of them could
have a heat stroke and who knows where
it goes from there you know they might
not think it right now but I think uh
you know we did help them out
today
[Music]